[Music]
in today's eight on your side americans
pay the highest brand name prescription
drug prices in the world
three to four times as much as other
nations that according to the latest
report from this year's prescription
price watch report
lee purvis assisted in this report she's
the director of health care costs and
access in aarp's public policy institute
she says spending increases driven by
high and growing drug prices affect all
americans in some way
those with private health coverage will
pay more in cost sharing and higher
premiums
and increased government spending will
ultimately lead to higher taxes or cuts
to public programs
she says all of us can do the following
to help lower our prescription drug
costs
i think the most important thing that
anyone can do is talk to their
pharmacist or their prescriber
there is often a lower cost alternative
that's available to treat your condition
and it's really important to find out
whether one is available
something else that's incredibly
important for medicare beneficiaries is
the extra help program which can help
cover a lot of your out-of-pocket costs
and your premium costs
pervis says retail prices for some 260
brand name prescription drugs
increased an average of 2.9 percent
between the years of 2006 and 2020
while the general inflation rate was 1.3
percent over the same period